Okay. Yes and no.
(Russian)
Okay. Next up,
I am a powerful woman.
(Russian)
Wow, great job dude.
Thank you so much.
All right.
May I please have five latkes
and a cup of borscht?
Okay.
(Russian)
Holy fucking shit dude.
How are you so good at this?
I'm a Russian Jew.
It's in my blood.
Me too. Okay here we go.
Continuing on.
Would you like me
to urinate on you strong man?
(Russian)-
Wait. You really think
you're gonna need that one?
Okay if I'm going to
successfully infiltrate Russia,
I'm gonna have to be
able to speak the language
to seduce
a cultural influencer,
plus you know how dictators
love their piss play.
I just want to prepared
for this new sci-fi world
we live in where the rules
change on the daily.
Oh my god.
Speaking of which dude,
I just got my knife
for my Go-bag.
So I'm gonna be like,
get out of here buddy.
Hey sucker,
that's my satchel.
Sure.
My Go-bag is gonna be set.
Okay.
Next up, so you definitely
hacked the election.
(together)
The election!